robert spencer you're the scholar on
islam your new book is out
about muhammad and you talk about how
the arabs
in the time of muhammad
did not believe in islam the way we know
it today what does that mean
well it's very strange but if you look
for example at the archaeological
evidence
the early coins that were minted by the
arab rulers
inscriptions that they put on buildings
that they built
there are a lot of times they have
crosses on them now islam
says that the cross is an insult to
allah that jesus was not crucified
and would not have been crucified
because allah would not allow his
prophet to be defeated
there's also a hadith in which muhammad
says that jesus
will come back at the end of the world
and break all the crosses now the idea
that muslims had this in their minds
and then put coins put crosses on their
coins
and crosses on their buildings it's
absurd it's much more likely that the
prohibition on crosses
came later which means that the whole
canonical story of islam's origins is
false
you